дорогі українці виду серце кручена у
всіх із днем ​​знань
цей день навіть символічною винним на рік
і про те, що шкіра назвеш нове-2 q
спраги винен і мужі в чиїсь си і
сьогодні проступають донів що не дуже
багато і дужки від дурнів цілу руку
втекла з кільки змі сиденьки в неї
світлі орендована 11000 нападу дитина
чани наші дороги porsche та класних та
міністерству свитої наук і встигнувши брати
з читером та практиками сноук вівцям та з
бочками шкутильгати щастя допитував aion
уілл у програми початку ви і школи для
нас дурова жила його щоб створ або
такі у нові що де ти про дільничні
школі відривала я киснеш у свиту я
костана грунтів ну і для того що до
ліван і могли успішно продовжу ось з
військових джоана і спритність йому не пишуть і
здоров'я та
інтерес і запал до гармат у нового і
донів чане
так ось ще одна категорія з
наші старшокласники та студенти які
вступив і
до вищих початкових закладів обидва учні
вступив і до професії, але технічних
початкових закладі
ящеру витаю також і всю категорію мологе
там у що для них навчання будеш з
вкладишем і зелених з них
інтелектуальний фронт боротьби за владу
на мій but я хочу паба стиснутої м щоб
сидні навчання та пезаро стартував та
більш інтенсивним і тиковим виконаним
і живого спинку vanya сперли нам та
людське думкою і можна вести швидкість
100 тис. батьком студентським шансом я
канай красивіше
для побуду ви слова maybe качиного
шановний бочкою і розумію як у їхній виліт
через своїх дітей і навіть спа девайси що
все про свити анни
успіх брати розум вам і створ маяк
краще розумом і
для які свого свити наших дітей коли я
дивуюсь
nov 4 викладочний в який відсоток системі
усвяти дуже часто мою на воду за куплю
ось з них саму бачену і жир важку
проц і дорогі екологи широти чу вам
багата
здоров'я сили духу і над клини для того
щоб цей торговий початковий рік а наша
ж kill switch on часто вимірюється в
польшу шаргунів чайним та вона календарним
і раком і ми змогли провести пли дно та і
дихає і чоловіки влади доступ у наших
українських дітей та мологи дай окисні про
святі вчора витаю широкі зусилля святу
днем знань
слава Україні